j'accueille maintenant maître véronique
robert avocats de la défense en droit
criminel
m robert bonsoir alors on vient le voir
depuis hier beaucoup de réactions à
cette affaire est ce que l'école est
allé trop loin parce que certains
invoquent la jurisprudence qui
permettrait donc la fouille dans les
écoles à condition qu'ils ne soient pas
abusif voire italie trop mal et comme il
est collé est allé trop loin parce que
la fouille qui est permise dans les
écoles suivant les enseignements
jurisprudentielle c'est ce sont les
fouille sommaire
donc ce sont des fouilles qui concerne
par exemple les sacs à dos les poches
peut-être les vêtements mais de manière
très superficielle les chaussures là la
décision de la cour suprême sur laquelle
se basent les intervenants dans ce
dossier le lot de ce que j'entends
depuis hier et une décision qui
concernait un garçon à qui on avait
demandé de vider ses poches
il l'avait fait lui même donc de vider
ses poches et de soulever un bout du bas
de son pantalon
c'est un genre de fouilles comme ce
qu'on peut appeler une fouille sommaire
rapport à une fouille à lima par une
fouille à nu à l'heure la définition de
la fouille à nu écouter adoptée par la
cour suprême elle est assez longue mais
ce qu'on peut en retenir c'est qu'il
s'agit d'une fouille où la personne est
complètement dévêtue
ce quelqu'un ici et où on procède à
l'examen visuel de sa personne ce qui
n'est pas le cas ici ou au à la fouille
de ses sous vêtements
alors on est face à une fouille à nu
parce que la personne est complètement
nus et confié ses sous vêtements
alors oui ça répond à l'égal du tout du
tout pas du tout alors maintenant on
sait pas légal c'est le protocole sur
lequel on se base présentement est un
protocole qui basé sur la jurisprudence
canadienne qui permet certaines fouilles
dans les écoles qui doivent être
effectuées de manière raisonnable mais
la fouille à nu dans un contexte
scolaire c'est pas raisonnable
ça ne peut pas exister l'artisanat est
une atteinte à l'aide à la vie privée et
à l'intégrité à l'intégrité physique
corporelle d'une jeune femme surtout les
fouilles à nu ce sont des fous qui sont
très très très exceptionnellement
utilisent
la méthode policière pendant une dame or
s'il ya un mandat d'arrestation alors
mandat d'arrestation ou un mandat de
fouiller cette personne le il pourrait y
avoir une fouille une fouille à nu
maintenant dans le cas d'une arrestation
un policy peut décider de procéder à une
fouille à nu
encore une fois de mana de manière très
exceptionnelle après avoir mis la
personne en état d'arrestation de
manière légale c'est-à-dire on lui lit
ses droits le droit au silence le droit
à l'avocat
la personne peut appeler un avocat et le
policy peut décider de procéder à une
fouille à nu s'il a des motifs
raisonnables et probables de croire que
kylie a d'abord une urgence un danger
réel
dans ce cas ci la direction il est
heureusement invoquait la pause le fait
qu'elle aurait eu de la drogue sur elle
donc c'était peut-être une menace à la
sécurité des autres élèves
c'est pas une menace mais même même dans
une situation policière une intervention
policière il n'y aurait pas écouté
jusqu'au policière mais je n'ai jamais
vu une situation comme celle le même
temps le code des arrestations de mes
clients et clients on ne procède pas à
une fouille à nu pour une possession de
cannabis
alors qu'est ce que les policiers
auraient fait pareil cas peut-être qu'il
aurait suivi jusqu'à ce que la
transaction stupéfiants et lieux et à ce
moment là on arrête parce qu'on est on
prend la transaction flagrant délit mais
on ne procède pas une fouille à nu pour
un trafic de cannabis
mais je me faire l'avocat du diable mais
en appelant la police c'est ce qu'on
avait décidé de faire est ce qu'on
n'aurait pas judiciariser
automatiquement le dossier alors que là
c'est la direction de l'école qui qui a
fait la foule batterie c'est préférable
d'appeler la police dans ce cas là
j'aurais préféré que cet enfant le soin
week les policiers interviennent parce
que je ne crois pas qu'elle aurait vécu
une fouille à nu si des policiers est
intervenue
d'autre part si la direction de l'école
avait trouvé du cannabis sur elle
on aurait fait quoi on aurait appelé la
police probablement alors je suis un peu
blanc blanc bonnet bonnet blanc j'ai
l'impression mais quand on parle de
maintenant mettre d'autres balises de
revoir un peu cette réglementation fond
on ferait ça pour rien parce que ce
n'est pas écrit finalement ce n'est pas
permis alors il faudrait peut-être
simplement ajouté cette fouille dont on
parle ici dans le protocole n'est pas
une fouille à nu c'est très clair les
pour les gérer ça c'est très clair que
jamais la cour suprême ne permit la
fouille à nu des élèves m robert merci
beaucoup ça me fait plaisir